[Music]
hey you guys here we are back again
it's monday yeah hopefully you guys can
hear us
it almost sounds good it seems kind of
quiet in here i don't really know why
and the damn fan going in there it's the
uh it's not the computer it's the uh
the party lights oh it's the damn laser
and you know what's weird is that it was
making that noise even when it was off
like i came in this morning and it
wasn't on and it was like making that
fan noise i don't think it was doing
that yesterday just unplug the cord out
of the back
yeah that's what i'm gonna have to do
because it's like i didn't notice it
yesterday but when i came in today it
was like really really loud it's
probably a fan to keep it
keep it cool yeah i guess though i don't
know why it needs to be going all the
time because it's [ __ ] freezing in
this room but you know what i mean
all right so uh this might be kind of a
like a little brief one today but i did
want to kind of talk about this movie a
little bit because this is one
that shutter just added um
last week i think now this is an irish
crime thriller it's not really a horror
movie but it's more it's more like a
crime thriller
and this came out in 2019 originally
and um it's called a good woman is hard
to find
now this i guess it premiered at
fantasia like last year it didn't get a
theatrical release here it got a
theatrical release in the uk and
you know i don't know how well it did
over there um but it didn't get like a
real wide release it's very independent
it was actually shot in belfast
uh partly and then i think some of it
was shot in belgium as well
so it's set in ireland and it's about
this woman named sarah
and she has two kids and her husband has
been
murdered um basically her husband was
murdered like just in the middle of the
day like in the park at their housing
estate
and because the cops um presume
that he was a drug dealer they basically
tell her
you know oh hey you know we don't really
care who did it because it's a bunch of
criminals so [ __ ] off like you know
move on with your life or whatever so
um she's kind of like trying to like
deal with these two kids that she has
and like her mom
sucks and is really [ __ ] and is always
making horrible like uh
you know making like real sideways
comments about her
and about like her ex-husband or her uh
dead husband and whatnot
so her life not going too well plus she
doesn't have much money obviously and
she lives on this estate
and um the place she lives is nice but
it just seems like everybody
like a lot of people have a lot of
misconceptions about her because one
because they perceived that her husband
was a drug dealer and two because they
perceive her to be poor
so it's always kind of like when she has
money everybody's like oh hey she's been
out prostituting herself or whatever
it's just like that kind of [ __ ]
so she has like a lot of [ __ ] to deal
with so
only a few minutes into the movie it so
happens
that there's this kind of petty criminal
petty drug dealer type of dude named
tito
and he decides he's going to steal a
bunch of drugs
from a local crime boss a nightclub
owner named leo
now he's running down the street trying
to escape from the from these uh you
know
the big crime boss people and he busts
into her house
and they don't see him so he decides hey
i'm gonna stash the drugs here
and because nobody knows who you are or
like where i am and i can just kind of
stay here and stay on the down low until
i sell all the drugs
now even though this dude is a [ __ ]
he does actually like offer to give her
a cut
and so she's kind of like obviously she
doesn't want this
dude like in her house but then she's
like well [ __ ] i kind of need the money
too so it's like she's real like
conflicted about it
and the thing about her character too is
that she's real because they kind of
established this like early on in the
movie
that she's real kind of like a doormat
kind of you know because even her mom
says you're too soft and you let people
walk all over you and stuff like that
so you know when this bad [ __ ] starts to
happen like happens she feels like she
can't really do anything about it
so then about the halfway point so this
is good because it sets up this real
tense kind of
i like too that they made like her
character is very
you know mousy and and everything and
then tito
is a dick like obviously he broke into
her house he's stashing drugs there and
she has two little kids and it's really
dangerous and she doesn't like the
situation
but he does give her money like he
brings her candy and [ __ ] like that
sometimes so he does have like a nice
side to him so i like that they didn't
just like make him a villain
but then like about halfway through
something happens
that kind of changes the whole dynamic
of like
how it goes and from then it just starts
like spiraling
i don't know if i want to say spiraling
out of control but some [ __ ] happens in
the middle and i won't spoil it because
like i said this is a pretty uh
new movie um and she basically has to
ovary up and uh yeah
yeah and uh and has to like defend her
children
from this [ __ ] storm that's coming her
way because of something that happens in
the middle
so as i said shutter just added this not
too long ago
and don't don't go into it expecting it
to be a horror movie because it's not
it's a crime thriller
um and like i said it's irish i really
really liked this movie i thought it was
like really well done like the tense
the tension was really well done i think
like my favorite part of it
probably was uh sarah it's it's either
bulger or bulgur i know she's been in
some other things i've heard her last
name pronounced both ways
she's [ __ ] great in this i mean she
is just
you are immediately like you know kind
of sympathetic with her character like
because she's just kind of getting [ __ ]
on all the time and she seems like
such a nice person and she doesn't
deserve like all this crap that's
happening to her so you really like
empathize with her right away
and then all of this bad [ __ ] starts
happening you're just like oh man this
poor woman you know what i mean
and then so and then like when tito
shows up and there's like this really
good like tense like dynamic between
them because you don't know
like if he's gonna flip out or you don't
like know what the [ __ ] is going on
and then when the really bad [ __ ]
happens then you're like oh no like now
her
life is really going to be [ __ ] up so
yeah this is like it's a really
really good movie i mean i really really
enjoyed it i thought it was like really
compelling
i thought it was like the story was
really good i've seen like some other
reviews like a lot of the reviews that
seem to be like really positive
a couple of people said this like oh
they liked the first half
better like before the big bad thing
happened in the middle and
then it kind of becomes more of like uh
you know
more of like a thriller in the sense
that you know
you know something we've seen before
kind of yeah um which i guess you could
kind of make that because but that
didn't bother me at all because like i
said i didn't really know the direction
it was going in
so you know um yeah so if you like crime
thrillers and you have shutter and you
haven't seen this for some reason
then uh yeah i would recommend checking
it out yeah i didn't see it
yeah i think you were missed the first
15 minutes you missed the first
like 20 30 minutes of it you missed like
quite a bit yeah i couldn't get into it
because i missed it because you missed
the beginning and a lot of [ __ ] like
happened in the beginning that was like
set up i'm not going to give a
complicated opinion on it yeah but it
did seem to be shot competently
that can have decent score good acting
yeah but i thought she was
she was really good at it and the guy
that played tito was good that's all
that's the only sensible thing i can say
about it if i make any
comments in that because i didn't
because you didn't really know and you
didn't really know what was going on and
stuff like that
but yeah i would definitely recommend it
if you like crime thrillers i thought it
was a really good one
um also somebody i can't remember who it
was but somebody requested
that we review a movie on netflix i
think it's from 2018
called uh the night comes for us and um
i think it's indonesian and it's
supposed to be like super violent i'm
like i've been i've been
[ __ ] man we've had better better luck
with the foreign movies lately
a lot of times and when you talk about
i've seen a lot of really good
indonesian
films because only the real good ones
end up on netflix
i think that's what it is it's just
because i mean we're american and we
have the american netflix so of course
it's we're going to get like all the
american movies so it's going to seem
like there's a lot more shitty ones
because just because there's more
more shitty movies we only get the ones
that like you know that got attention
like at other festivals around the world
so you know they got picked up
they've been vetted by the time we get
them exactly so i do think it's not so
much i'm sure they have like tons of
shitty movies that we
that we would never see probably
but yeah so we will probably watch that
one uh later on tonight and then we'll
come on and review it tomorrow
and i think i want to review i'm not
sure where i can i think you can rent it
on youtube but i don't know if
like amazon prime or something has it i
want to see
um possessor because that was directed
by brandon cronenberg
that would be david cronenberg's son i
think it's his first
one okay um and i've heard it's really
good and like really [ __ ] up and stuff
so i'll have to look for that one too
like over the next couple days like i
said amazon prime might have it i think
you can rent it on youtube but so maybe
we'll have to do it on there
but those are the ones that will
probably be coming up later in the week
unless something else pops up that more
strikes my fancy
but yeah sorry this is kind of a short
one today but like i said i don't want
to spoil the movie
it's kind of a new one and we did kind
of a long one yesterday and
we're kind of tired so
[Laughter]
so uh thanks everybody for stopping by
for this little short one and we will
see you again
on the next one tomorrow bye